[Music]
oh there you are Cedric
sup dude tis well Cedric tis well you
can ask you a question oh um why the
hell are you dressed like this and what
the hell did you do to your bike you
iron
I'm steampunk now yeah I don't know what
that is man jules verne it I seriously
think that you have cracked man alright
like like in your mind nah I ain't
cracked up I live in a clock now
umbrellas and blimps you're wearing a
top hat with a door on it I'm just in
here last Lemony Snicket up in this
[ __ ] but you what's with you what's
with me I'll tell you what I'm i'm a
ill-ass normal mother who've been
waiting for his friend for hour and 10
minutes
underneath the goddamn bridge we're two
homeless put sounds good sir could you
point me in the direction of the nearest
apothecary if you're talking about the
drugstore it's right there on the corner
what time does it close it closes at ten
o'clock man you've been here a million
times mmm
I'll check just to be sure make sure
it's still okay
I'm telling you Levi if you put that
piece of pipe up to your eye and use it
as a telescope I cannot be your friend
anymore yep
still open all right I have to go then
you try it no no I'm not gonna try it
because it's a piece of pipe and it
doesn't have any lenses in it therefore
it's not a telescope yes but how could
you be sure science I'm gonna look to
this piece of pipe and if it doesn't
work like a telescope then we finally
done man like not homies anymore we're
done
[Music]
Louis Sachar why
what you think
years
- that would actually work Cedric is
just dead
you look so ridiculous right now
Oh
say goodbye ratatouille what what is
that
[Music]
you